the freezing fog is thick as we speed
out across the azole sea
crimea which was annexed by russian
forces eight years ago is not far from
here
anton has come to check the area he will
fish when the winter fishing season
starts next week
he insists on covering his face because
he like hundreds of ukrainian fishermen
has been detained by russian naval
intelligence in recent years
he says he was taken to a russian naval
base in kirch at the entrance to the
black sea where he was interrogated and
held for 15 days before being released
there are many obstacles access to the
sea is difficult russians don't allow us
to work properly they approach us and
start pushing us back harass us
we can't do anything of our small boats
against their equipment
it's impossible to prove to them we have
a right to be here it's pointless
trying the wreck of a soviet fishing
trawler appears on an island around
which ukrainian fishermen now cast their
nets less frequently
soviet-built houses where fishermen used
to stay stand derelict near the shore
we're about 20 kilometers off the coast
fishermen tell us that normally in this
area there'd be around 100 ukrainian
fishing vessels
operating
but they say that number is dwindling
fast because of fears of russian naval
patrols
in 2003 russia and ukraine signed an
agreement which allows both countries to
fish anywhere in the azov sea
but since 2014 when russia annexed
crimea moscow has increased its naval
presence and taken greater control of
these waters and the larger black sea
which the azov is connected to via the
kirch strait
in december the ukrainian navy said
russia blocked
75 per cent of the azov by issuing
navigational warnings
recent large-scale russian naval
exercises off crimea have fueled fears
that the kremlin is preparing to invade
ukraine by sea something russia
continues to deny
ukraine lost 70 percent of its fleet
when russia seized control of crimea and
sevastopol the black sea port city
ukraine's government is buying small
naval patrol vessels from nato partners
but seems powerless to better protect
fishermen
of course i'm worried we go far out to
sea we might not come back it's good if
the russians inform our families that
they've taken us but there are many
instances when they file forged cases
against us and you risk being put in a
russian prison for years
at the fish market traders say they are
feeling the financial fallout of
russia's actions at sea
the situation has got really bad
no russian tourists small amount of fish
from the boats because of problems at
sea
the fishing industry is suffering and
that means we do too
we repeatedly ask the ukrainian navy for
comment about how it can better protect
fishermen from what the government calls
russian aggression but the navy refused
because of what it says are security
issues
anton is afraid of fishing these icy
waters in the weeks ahead a sea now
increasingly under russian control
charles stratford al jazeera the azov
sea southern ukraine